- [Narrator] Let's play a game.
Think of a famous painting.
Guess what?
You just thought of me.
Today, I'm the world's
most renowned work of art,
but it wasn't always this way.
My story is full of surprises,
and it all began in a studio in Florence.
(upbeat orchestral music)
Well, here's the master
himself, Leonardo da Vinci.
He worked on me on and off for a few years
towards the end of his career.
- You're a minor work, my dear,
some interesting shading, nothing more.
- [Narrator] We'll just see about that.
Over the next 300 years, I
hung quietly in French palaces
and royal bathrooms.
The things I've seen.
- [Napoleon] I want you.
- [Narrator] Until finally I
was noticed by a man who had
already made quite a name for himself.
When Napoleon chose me to
hang on his bedroom wall,
people took notice.
- I look forward to sleeping
with you, my cherie.
- [Narrator] After he had his
whole exile from France thing,
they tossed me on a wall at The Louvre.
But at this point, I was still
just another Renaissance portrait.
Until one night.
(daunting, suspenseful music)
- Bella.
- [Narrator] I was stolen!
It was pandemonium.
Paris was in an uproar.
The police hauled people
in left and right.
The hysteria hit a fever pitch
when the police suspected and interrogated
one of the most famous artists
in the world, Pablo Picasso.
(officer speaking French)
(man gasping)
But Picasso was innocent.
The thief turned out to
be an Italian carpenter.
He was caught in Florence.
- Mama mia.
- [Narrator] And I returned to The Louvre.
From that day forward,
I became the darling
of the art world.
Everyone wanted to see
Napoleon's da Vinci painting
Picasso was suspected of stealing.
Soon, tourists crowded
in and most people forgot
why I was famous in the first place.
That might raise some
eyebrows, but not mine
since I don't have any.
Oh, you didn't notice I
don't have any eyebrows?
I told you, I'm full of surprises.
(soft chiming music)